in this video we're going to explore how
a two by two matrix can be interpreted
as representing a transformation on the
coordinate plane so let's just start
with some examples or some conceptual
ideas so the first conceptual idea is
that any point on our coordinate plane
here and this of course is our x-axis
and this is our y-axis can be
represented by a combination of two
vectors
you could have this vector right over
here that goes exactly one unit in the
horizontal direction we can represent
that
as a vector like this one zero when you
write a vector vertically like this the
convention is that the top number here
is what we're doing in the x direction
and then the bottom number the zero is
what we're doing in the vertical
direction or the y direction so this is
the one zero vector and then this right
over here what would we call that
well that we would call the zero one
vector because it doesn't go at all in
the x direction and it only goes up one
in the y direction
now just to feel good that any point on
the coordinate plane can be represented
as a weighted sum of these let's just
pick a point at random let's say this
point right over here let's call it
point a and you could represent that as
a vector that looks something like this
i'll do it as a dotted line
but this could be represented as a
positional vector like that
and of course if we're thinking about in
coordinates we would just say this is at
the coordinate 3
comma 1. the x coordinate is at 3 the y
coordinate is 1. but if we wanted to
express it in terms of a vector
we could write it as
3
1.
the x
direction we're moving 3 from the origin
positive 3 in the y direction we're
moving 1 to get there and you could see
that we can represent this as a weighted
sum of these two vectors we can write
this as this is the same thing as 3
times
our
1 0 vector
1
0
plus
1 times our 0 1 vector
0 1 vector and you could see it visually
this yellow vector that points to point
a right over there
you can have three of this vector one
two
and then three
and then one of the orange vector
now i said that i would
explain how two by two matrices can
represent a transformation
and the way that you could think about
it is if i have a two by two matrix that
looks like
this
so let me just draw the matrix
where the first column is 1 0 and then
the second column is 0 1 this just tells
you what to do with these two vectors i
know this might be a little bit
confusing at first but let's let's just
walk through it together so the way i've
represented it this first column says
what is the transformation you want to
apply to this one zero vector this first
blue vector well we're just keeping it
one zero so we're not changing it it's
the same one zero vector here one zero
vector here likewise zero one vector
here zero one vector here
so this
two by two matrix actually represents
what's sometimes known as the identity
transformation it maps any point on the
coordinate plane back to itself it
doesn't change the points but i'm
showing this because now i'm going to
show a two by two matrix that represents
a non-identity transformation for
example let me draw the matrix again
so let's say
i have the matrix instead of 1 0 here
i'm going to write a 2 1 here instead of
a 0 1 here let me write a 1 2.
so in this transformation what we're
doing is we're turning this 1 0 vector
into a 2 1 vector you're going to see
what i'm talking about in a second so
what does a 2 1 vector look like let me
do it in that color
well we go 2 in the x direction 1 in the
y direction so it's going to look like
this
it's going to look like
that
and then what does a 1 2 vector look
like well it goes 1 in the x direction
and then 2 in the y direction so it
looks like this
and the way that this represents a
transformation is that anything that was
a weighted sum
of the 1 0 and the 0 1 vectors
originally you can now view as a
weighted sum of the two one and the one
two vectors and so we can now think of
another point a prime that's not going
to be three of the one zeros and one of
the zero ones we can think of it as let
me write it over here
as three
of the
two ones
plus
one
of the
one twos
one of these
one two so where would that put that now
well we're going to do three of the two
ones so this is
one of them
this is two of them
and then this is three of them and then
i'm going to have one of the one two
vectors this orange vector right over
here and so
i'm going to have one of those
and so that will take me to
a prime this is my new point after
the transformation i go to a prime so
i've gone from this point a to this
point a prime and this two by two matrix
is telling us how to transform
now we can do that with multiple points
now if i talk about a point here at the
origin that was originally at the origin
point b well that's 0 of the orange
vector 0 of the blue vectors so even
after the transformation is going to be
0 of the 2 1 vector and 0 of the 1 2
vectors so it's just going to stay in
place it's just going to map to itself
so b is equal to b prime and we could
also imagine another point
let's say
right over here let's call that point c
well point c is originally two of the
blue vectors and none of the orange
vectors so after the mapping it'll be
two of the two one vectors and none of
the one two vectors so two of the two
ones so if you go one two
and then none of the one twos you're
going to get c prime right over there
and so notice if originally you had a
triangle between a b and c let me draw
it like this so originally you had this
triangle abc
what is it now gotten matt what is it
now mapped to
well it's now mapped to this big
triangle do my best to draw it
relatively
straight so we land on target so that's
that side
and then we have
this side going from b prime to c prime
and then we want to connect that side
from c prime to a prime now you might be
saying sal how do you know that the
lines map onto other lines how do you
know this transformation didn't all of a
sudden make this line squiggly or zigzag
and that's one of the interesting
properties of the type of transformation
we're talking about a two by two matrix
will represent a linear transformation
and there's two ways to think about it
in this context a linear transformation
will always map the origin onto itself
and it will always map a line onto
another line it won't turn that line
into a curve or it won't make it zigzag
somehow now the last thing you might be
wondering is hey what about all these
transformations we had from geometry
these similarity transformations things
like rotations reflections dilations can
you do those with matrices and the
simple answer is yes you can do them as
long as you keep the origin in place and
you can actually using a 2x2 matrix come
up with a whole series of other linear
transformations that are much more let's
call it exotic than just the rotations
reflections and dilations